please welcome back to our show the very
funny Tommy John Egan thank you thank
you my girlfriend I just had a baby
thank you we didn't plan it we didn't
plan it we talked about it once
she said I'm thinking about stopping
birth control I said great I'd love to
have a baby in a year or two turns out
in a year or two I'm gonna have a one or
two year old baby not quite what I meant
I wanted a new baby in a year or two not
a dumb old baby I've got a bunch of
dents in it dust all over it there's a
new one out with faster internet when
you your girlfriend pregnant and you
tell people you have to say my
girlfriend's pregnant and we're very
excited about it because if you only say
my girlfriend's pregnant they don't know
what to say back or what face to make it
you my girlfriend's pregnant that's an
it takes a village we had a girl people
aren't as excited when you have a girl
you have a boy they're like that's great
he's probably gonna be a quarterback you
have a girl they're like boo good luck
what are you gonna do when she's 18 and
she starts dating she's negative 1 month
old can you stop alluding to her banging
dudes it's kind of rude I travel a lot
so we have to get a nanny my
girlfriend's in a nanny resume with a
photo attached she's 26 years old
smoking hot I said nope that's not our
nanny that nanny's gonna ruin someone
else's life
she goes are you gonna bang the nanny I
said no I'm not gonna bang the nanny but
I promise everyone who has ever banged
the nanny said the exact same thing if I
were writing a book on how to bang the
nanny step 1 say you're not gonna bang
the nanny step 2
bang that nanny I wouldn't do that cuz
I'm a great dad already I went to every
doctor's appointment that she had the
first doctor's appointments doctor was
surprised she goes it's great that
you're here a lot of guys don't come to
these appointments and then when they do
come they just wanna know how much is
this gonna cost and how long can we keep
having sex and I was like and then you
would say to them sex doesn't become an
issue until the 8th month from my
personal experience
she becomes gigantically large she's
pregnant it's normal so we're eight
months pregnant one night in bed I said
come on over here let's get this started
she said no I can't I won't get up there
I'll squish you
it's a babe you're beautiful you're not
gonna squish me climb aboard
then she did and I was like oh he's
heavier than I thought the baby weighed
an estimated 6 pounds and the rest was
water weight which apparently she had
mixed with cement
because it was very heavy you can't get
out of it that's rude can't do that you
were right
you are squishing me I'll never doubt
you again
we did it mission accomplished my goal
wasn't for me to have a good time
my goal was for her to have a good time
and for me not to make noises like I'm
moving a couch while she did it she's
rocking around up there I'm like whoa
we're never gonna get through the door
like this are you even lifting your end
that's it for me thank you guys very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
Johnny Johnny getting everybody
[Applause]